c'est pas ma came c'est pas mon truc
c'est pas moi je ne me mets pas de vent
je me dis pas tiens vite préféré la
grotte des biotech vaut par exemple fait
bien sûr parce que benhaim alors ce
matin j'ai eu au téléphone vous jure t
vrai je leur racontais des spectateurs
elle me dit oui
là cet hiver je dois florent je vais
visiter les musées au bas mot dire oui
si elle le dit cyril très simplement dit
si tu oublies que je suis une hôtel où
se moque de moi parce que je me dis que
j'ai visité des musées sait pas non plus
combien de musulmans en france il ya
florence essai qui faisait chez florence
et c'est d'abord à bout sadique et des
musées florence a bien sûr ah oui ah oui
c'est une florence a donc fait à votre
niveau
au nom des sanctions je vais vous dire
quand aurait alors jouer alors à le
temps d'étudier florence chez elle et la
rentrée est bien entendu je peux venir
alors a le temps de voyager du parti
pour l'émission c'est une très belle
relation familiale mais je suis pas très
client alors